des américains à beaune on est plutôt
habitué à en croiser mais ce groupe là
sous ses airs de simples touristes est
un peu particulier
ce sont des mécènes venue de boston new
york ou encore de la nouvelle-orléans
tous amoureux du patrimoine et de
l'architecturé française
alors la craie grasse et le siège de
l'évêque oui c'est la basilique c'est un
titre honorifique qui est dessiné par le
vatican une église
baptisé
organise donc une fois par an un voyage
d'une semaine dans une région pour leur
faire découvrir les prix de restauration
qu'ils ont soutenu financièrement et
leur faire également découvrir les
autres trésors architecturaux de la
région une chance pour la france en 40
ans l'association a soutenu 650 projets
publics ou privés pour plus de 14
millions de dollars
rien d'anormal pour les membres de la
délégation la sauvegarde et la
transmission du patrimoine aux
générations futures n'a pas de prix vous
avez des trésors dans chaque région de
la france qui est la réflexion delà de
la culture locale nous avons beaucoup de
monuments nationaux mais nous n'avons
pas tran devra été comme on trouve en
france
une visite marathon de cinq jours où le
groupe loin de passer incognito peut
être invités à soutenir des projets à
chaque détour de ruelle
mais heureusement après l'effort le
réconfort
car le patrimoine français c'est aussi
sa gastronomie et surtout ses mains
c'est un peu pour ça je suis venu parce
que je suis collector du vin et j'adore
tout ce qui avait un français aux états
unis on n'a pas le droit de boire dans
21 ans et un trajet de 10 à
château de talent mais de sully abelli
de fontenay ou encore forge de buffon 40
sites bourguignons ont été soutenus
depuis 1982 pour un montant de 360
milles dollars
en cette fin d'après midi il reste un
site à visiter l'abbaye de cîteaux
faut pas
tant après la restauration de la
bibliothèque et de sa magnifique galerie
les moines veulent réhabiliter le
définitoire l'ancêtre du parlement
européen puisque c'était là que se
réunissaient une fois par an les
cisterciens venus de toute l'europe si
on devait entièrement restauré des
bâtiments sur fonds propres on n'y
arriverait pas on arrive à vivre du
produit de notre travail pour le
quotidien mais pour une restauration de
cette ampleur là on n'en a pas les
moyens d'autant plus que ce bâtiment ci
ne sera pas directement utiles à la vie
de la communauté de sitôt il sera utile
au rayonnement culturel de la france au
rayonnement culturel des cisterciens
donc il est
légitime de demander à d'autres de nous
aider dans ce projet un chantier
monumental de plus de 13 millions
d'euros que la french héritage society
devrait soutenir en partie en
collaboration avec la fondation du
patrimoine il était mon père l'histoire
de ce lieu est la raison pour laquelle
ce projet important c'est ça qui parle
aux américains aux gens qui au mécène en
fait c'est d'avoir une belle histoire et
c'est leur façon de soutenir le
parlement français
reste à espérer pour les moines que la
délégation ne soit pas trop sollicité
pendant le reste de son voyage